if you want to know how to improve your
side hustle then this video is for you
what's up elimination it's Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I want to see explode out onto
the world now I often get asked by
people about their side hustle you've
started a business on the side you want
to turn it into your full-time income
and you're having a little bit of
struggle get into the place where you
want to be in today's video I'm gonna
share with you my seven ways on how to
really focus on and improve your site a
soul way number one is be consistent one
of the biggest challenges for
entrepreneurs we have a side hustle and
that's what you're trying to build up as
your company is you're just not
consistent you allow other things in
your life to get in your way and I get
it work is hard family relationships are
hard personal relationships are hard
sometimes you get home when you're just
dead tired if you are only spending one
day a week or two days a week starting
on your business it's gonna be really
hard to get the momentum that you need
to launch it to take it off to have a
lot of success with it and so what I
encourage people to do is spend at least
half an hour every single day no excuses
on your business you come home you're
dead tired you just want to go to sleep
you're still spending half an hour now
ideally you can be spending more but at
least half an hour because the momentum
starts to build up and suddenly things
start to happen for you where if you're
doing it on a Monday and then you don't
do it again until Friday and then the
next Tuesday and you're doing these
start and stop and start and stop and
start and stop you never give yourself
enough time and enough momentum to
actually build something special and so
you need to be consistent you don't need
to quit your job you don't need to go
all in but what you do need to do is be
consistent if you look at anybody who's
turned their side hustle into a
successful enterprise
they took consistent action every single
day that's number one and I think most
important tip to help you get going
[Music]
but this videos about seven ways so
let's get to way number two and that is
you need to actually love what you're
doing so many people pick a side hustle
because they think it's an opportunity
because they see a problem in the market
because their friends are complaining
say hey I can solve that or you're
looking at ink magazine and you see all
the list of hottest companies to start
in 2018 and so that's what you go off
and do that's not the way to do your
site hustle because you're gonna see
your site hustle has worked the minute
you see your business as work
you've lost because you've just bought
yourself a second job that's not what
you want
you're not just chasing opportunity
because you think it's hot you have to
actually love the work that you're doing
something that half an hour flies right
by three hours can fly right by because
you are enjoying the work today I'm
making YouTube videos I'm spending the
entire day I have my studio making
YouTube videos and I can't believe that
it's already what time is it
2:45 it's crazy we got here at 8:30 it's
already 2:45 I don't know where the time
went but I'm enjoying doing this for you
guys and so you need to find the work
that does not feel like work and when
you do that you'll be able to find more
times right you'll be daydreaming about
it while you're at work you'll be able
to work on it over your lunch break when
you get home you're excited to go and
work on that project as opposed to it
being a task or a job you don't need a
second job you need a side hustle that
can grow into a successful business
that's gonna come from you doing
something that you love we number three
is integrated with your job one of the
best ways to build your site hustle is
to find a job that somehow relates so
you're not just taking a job to make
money but you're taking a job to learn
to build contacts to understand how an
industry works so that may mean you
could do something within your current
job if it's not in the ideal industry
that you want to be in for your own
company maybe you quit your job and go
get a job in the industry to learn how
it works and I try to find somebody with
10 employees or less some of who you
look up to and might want to be like in
a couple years go work for them so you
understand the industry but even if you
don't want to quit your job and go get
that job try to find ways within your
current job to learn the skills you'll
need to be an entrepreneur so if you're
doing payroll as an example but part of
your business you need to learn how to
sell then can you take on any sales or
marketing
bonus projects at your current job most
employers if you volunteer yourself to
say hey I'd like to help work on this
project for free at my own cost without
taking away from the current work that
I'm doing most employers love that
almost no employees show that kind of
initiative and so if you need to learn
about sales and marketing maybe there's
a possibility of taking on some projects
and helping out in your current position
now even if you have nothing to do with
that and so taking on projects that will
build the skill set that you need to
bring to your business can be really
helpful finding ways to integrate your
current life and your current work
situation to give you the knowledge and
contacts to be able to build up your own
business on the side is super valuable
[Music]
hey what's up I'm John Sean meds from
the simple programmer channel and tip
number four is trust the process what do
I mean by trust the process I mean trust
that if you continue to work on your
side project every day and you continue
to work on that side hustle that
eventually you're going to get to where
you want to get but you just got to
believe in the process you've got to
trust the process and not focus so much
on the results a lot of times when you
start out when you've got a side hustle
and you want to make it your full-time
thing or you want to be successful at it
it's tempting to look at the results and
to get discouraged because you don't see
the results coming fast enough but
what's more important to do is to figure
out what's the process that's going to
make this new business of this new
venture successful and then keep on
doing the process eventually the results
will come and ultimately all that you
have control over in life is the process
and executing executing is the most
important thing once you trust the
process the results will come but only
if you stay in the game long enough to
actually get those results way number
five is get help
it's really hard to do everything on
your own especially the parts of your
business that you're not really good at
or want to be good at and so I've been
looking at how can I enlist people to
help me in my business and what can I do
to give value back to them so as an
example when I was starting my business
when I started my Evan Carmichael
business
I've even made money from my first
company and selling it but I hate
spending money till I make you money and
so I started finding ways to partner up
with friends to get their input to get
their help my first website was built by
a friend of mine
for free he picked a logo in the font
and we've actually kept that pretty
consistent over all the years and I came
because a buddy of mine wanted to help
me out and so chances are there's a lot
of people in your network who will want
to help you out if you just ask not
everybody needs to be paid for the work
that they're doing and maybe you could
pay a little bit part time on the side
if your business is slowly growing and
getting up there if you can involve
other people on your mission in your
journey you can go a lot faster than if
you try to do everything yourself and I
think a lot of people only think of
full-time employees
I can only hire somebody full-time into
my company and I can't do that until I'm
making enough to pay myself and pay them
if you wait that long it's going to take
you a long time before you have that
kind of income to do it and so recognize
that there are people right now in your
community in your circle of friends who
could contribute to helping your
business go forward if you just asked we
number six is sell more right revenue
solves a lot of problems you got to
start making money for your business and
one of the best ways to sell more is to
go back to your existing clients so
whatever you're doing as your side
hustle whether you're selling a product
are you selling a service try to find a
way to bring more value to your current
clients first I love the idea of
delivering like crazy so that you
provide just way more value than what
they expected so they expect it X but
you're giving them X plus y plus Z so
that they love you and you've really
really solved their problem solving
their problem just what they asked you
for should never be an option for you
you always have to add a plus 1 a plus 2
a plus 3 to help them feel like you
really insanely care about them cuz then
they're gonna come back they're gonna
want to buy more from you they're gonna
tell their friends about you somebody
who just solves their problem isn't melt
worthy enough is it is that a word
mouths were thee isn't worthy of
spreading the word about because you
just were okay you just it was expected
it's not extraordinary and so that's
your goal you want to over-deliver like
crazy go back to your current customers
see how you can turn that one off sale
in to an annual deal see how you
provide more value with them sell more
so that you can afford to eventually
quit your job and make this side hustle
your full-time business and way number
seven is model success whenever you
don't know what to do whenever you don't
know how an industry works the best
thing you can do is model success find
people who have done that thing whatever
your side hustle is find somebody who
has done it and they're doing it
full-time and they're doing it with a
team and they're doing it with a huge
empire that now they've built up from
scratch whatever you are doing somebody
has done it in a big way it may not be
exactly what you're doing but they've
done it in a different industry or a
slightly different industry in a big way
for me it was modeling Bill Gates I had
a biotech software company there was no
big biotech software company that I
could model when I was starting mine and
so I looked to Microsoft which is
another kind of software company and how
did Bill Gates get started zero to one
story that's what I wanted to do for my
own business and so looking at that
other software company taught me lessons
and Bill Gates saved my first company I
would have gone out of business without
learning from Bill Gates's story and so
whatever problem you're facing right now
somebody has already solved it and going
back looking at their story retracing
the roots and applying those lessons to
your situation can really dramatically
explode your growth so those are my
seven ways on how to improve your side
hustle I'd love to know from you which
one was your favorite which one you're
going to apply immediately into your
business did I miss an eight nine ten
that you want to add to the list leave
in the comments below I look forward to
hearing from you thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is
much love I'll see you soon if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon pay
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details